it's been two years since a young man's
gift of life was donated after a tragic
accident 18 year old michael siegler
passed away before his high school
graduation today his family reconnected
with another family who received the
ultimate gift from that tragic day i
miss him terribly every single solitary
day it's been a long and difficult road
for the ziegler family after losing
michael in a 2019 motorcycle accident
but his legacy his family says lives on
what mike chose to do you know by
becoming an organ donor
it's immeasurable
you know there are
eight lives
you know
that are
you know still living
umc honored the teen during this donor
walk if it wasn't for the donation from
him
then i would be gone that personal
decision has given texas resident harold
peck a new lease on life after he was
diagnosed with pulmonary fibrosis i was
probably within 30 days of passing away
and my skin had already turned gray and
everything and then we ended up getting
the call but that call he says was the
start of an even longer and emotional
path the first donor ended up having
pneumonia
the second donor they ended up finding
cancer in the donors kidneys
and
it just kind of kept rolling and finally
the sixth time we got a call and they
said come down and so we ended up coming
down and it was a perfect match when
someone decides to become an organ iron
tissue donor just like mikey they have
the ability to impact the lives of eight
others through organ donation and save
theirs and also heal and enhance the
lives of 75 or more through tissue and
ocular donations
[Music]
today an emotional encounter we have to
really
appreciate and cherish
everything that we can while we we have
the opportunity as both families
reconnect again over a young man's
decision to give the ultimate gift
oh my
family we definitely are family now
truly is the ultimate gift well
currently there are over a hundred and
seven thousand americans in the country
waiting for an oregon donation 600 of
them are right here in nevada head over
to 8newsnow.com to learn how you can
become a donor today